-After Nike announced
that former NFL quarterback
and activist Colin Kaepernick
would be the face
of its new ad campaign,
angry consumers
began posting photos
of themselves
burning their
Nike shoes and apparel.
Now, this story obviously has
some strong racial overtones,
and I'm not sure I'm
comfortable commenting on it.
-But I am!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah!
Okay, here's the thing,
white people.
I'm not saying you don't have
a right to protest.
I'm just saying you're doing
it the wrong way.
Why not burn your
shoes privately,
instead of putting it on the
Internet for everyone to see?
Why are you disrespecting
the hard-working people of Nike?
-Oh, I don't think
that's what they're --
-Protest is a right guaranteed
under the constitution,
but there is a
time and place for that.
And the Internet is neither
the time, nor the place.
-It's not?
-I'm tired of you people
politicizing shoes.
-Oh, wait, wait. I see.
You're just saying all
the stuff white people said
when Kaepernick
was kneeling, aren't you?
-You're damn right I am!
Whoo! Go ahead.
Burn your shoes, you dummies.
And if you don't have any Nikes,
take your ass down to the ATM,
take out $140, and burn that.
Whoo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Amber Ruffin, everybody!